you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
could you pay more for things which harm
the environment
we hear the view from westminster on
whether a carbon tax might be on the way
with temperature records in north
america and canada broken
numerous times this week is climate
change making the pacific northwest heat
wave
worse and the tension between protecting
nature
and promoting economic prosperity in
uganda
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those developing the solutions
now running a petrol or diesel car or
even using gas in your home
could be set to become more expensive
it's been reported that the government
is considering introducing a carbon
reduction scheme
which would see the cost of climate
damaging activities
increase the aim would be to persuade
people to switch
to greener alternatives helping the uk
meet its target to reach net zero
emissions
by 2050. our political correspondent
tamara cohen has
the details from westminster
it's being reported in the times that
families are looking at paying an extra
170 pounds
on their annual gas bills and an extra
100 pounds
for the average car user as a result of
these policies to cut
emissions now i understand these are the
sort of figures
that people in government are looking at
but i stress to me
that no decisions have been made and the
government will be consulting on all
this
later in the year it's all part of a
system called emissions
trading which the government is looking
at extending
to buildings and transport this is a
scheme under which
sectors that produce a lot of emissions
are charged more
the problem is they pass on some of
those costs
to consumers now while ministers always
say that they want to make their climate
policies as affordable as possible
they've been told off by their own
climate advisors
because they haven't really set out any
firm policies for how they get to the
target
of net zero emissions and that may well
be because
if it means higher bills in the short
term that's always going to be
a tough sell to north america now where
this week has seen
record-breaking heat in both the u.s and
canada
the pacific northwest is a region
normally known for its cool
rainy weather with the occasional hot
and sunny day mixed in
but in recent days it's been a very
different story portland and oregon
reached almost 47 degrees on monday
the average temperature for this time of
year would normally see highs of around
26 degrees
in washington state chelan county near
seattle reached 48 degrees on tuesday
while in canada litten in british
columbia broke the country's record for
the hottest temperature
three days in a row reaching 49.6
degrees celsius
before sunday temperatures in the
country had never passed 45 degrees
and it's all because of an extreme
weather event called a heat dome
it's caused by the atmosphere trapping
and heating air while compressing it
down
like a lid on a saucepan meteorologists
say the phenomenon has been
worsened by human-caused climate change
making extreme weather events
more common well let's bring in dr heidi
steltzer a climate scientist at the
department of environment and
sustainability at port
fort lewis college in colorado welcome
to you
what's your view is it possible to
attribute this heat wave to climate
change
it's a weather event it's a weather
event that's taking place
uh and bring our consciousness towards
concern for climate change
and i think that's different than saying
that we can attribute this to climate
change
so it brings our attention forward to
something
that's part of a weather system we don't
want to see more of
uh because it it sets an imbalance
um relative to the systems we have in
place for infrastructure for
human habitation of the north west and
the southwestern u.s
and we've heard a lot about this phrase
heat dome tell us a little bit more
about what that means
so the heat dome was centered here over
southwest u.s to
the one that was in early june uh and we
had really
hot times not as hot as the northwest is
now seeing and dry times and as the new
heat wave has
uh formed the heat dome has formed in
the northwest we've actually had really
good rain here in the southwestern
part of the u.s at least in my region uh
with um
almost record-setting wildflowers um
because
um it was hot and now it's wet um so
so there's you know pros there's there's
balance in the system
and what do you predict might happen in
the years ahead is it possible that heat
waves like this will become more
frequent
we know that climate change increases
the likelihood
of extreme climate events and
uh so the likelihood of an extreme event
in
an extreme event being more extreme
but what is forecast for the few uh the
years ahead
that's really up to us that's up to each
of us for decisions we make
uh and where and how we contribute to a
more caring
and coordinated effort to understand
what choices we can make that would
minimize the risk of more extreme events
dr heidi stelzer thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at the day's other
climate news and the president of the
seychelles has told sky news that richer
developed nations should help countries
on the front line of climate change he
spoke to our correspondent adam parsons
about witnessing the
reality of the climate crisis
i'm looking at the reality of things and
this is why
i want to portray myself as this island
boy
who grew up looking at the stars
enjoying the stars
and who suddenly fear that i might not
see the stars again
we're not responsible for that because
our emission is next to zero
but the developing the developed
countries the industrialized countries
are responsible
so there needs to be this new
working arrangement whereby those who of
course the damage
just like in everyday life you pay
compensation
where you cause the damage
the number of climate change cases being
brought to court
has more than doubled since 2015. that's
according to analysis by the grantham
institute which found that over a
thousand litigation cases have been
filed in the past six years
the number of strategic cases which aim
for wider action
has increased with many targeting
government inaction or lack of ambition
in reaching
climate goals and a paper has called on
scientists to find
potential solutions to the challenge of
plastic waste
it's currently cheaper to create new
plastic than recycle it
so developing more efficient ways of
using plastic as well as
upcycling products after use are a vital
step to finding a solution
one scientist described throwaway
culture as the biggest hurdle to
overcome
uganda has one of the most ambitious
environmental laws in the whole of
africa and was the first nation in the
continent to formally recognize the
rights of nature
in a similar way to those of humans but
there's a tension
for the developing nation between
protecting the environment
and improving people's lives through
economic development
more than half of ugandans live in
poverty and nearly a third
are unemployed so the discovery of huge
oil deposits offered a chance to
transform
the country's fortunes in april the
ugandan and tanzanian government
signed final agreements with the french
oil company total
and the china national offshore oil
corporation to extract around 1.7
billion barrels of oil
from underneath the northern section of
the albertine
rift an area of extraordinary
biodiversity
around lake albert now this huge area of
mountains valleys and wetlands
makes up just over one percent of
africa's land mass
but is home to more than half its birds
40
of mammals and around 500 species of
plants and animals
that aren't found anywhere else now once
developed
oil from the project will be pumped 900
miles to
tanga a port on the tanzanian coast
itself surrounded by mangroves
and coral reefs well jack losch is a
journalist who recently visited the site
and i spoke to him earlier and asked
about the biodiversity this project
might put at risk this
new mega oil project is located not only
one of the most biodiverse areas of the
african continent
but also on the planet it's in the
albertine risk
rift which is a huge colossal network of
mountains uh forests lakes and
grasslands that stretches across
multiple countries
the french oil firm total and massive
chinese oil corporation
are making the final moves to begin
extracting 1.7 billion barrels
worth of crude from there and yet uganda
does have
a new and ambitious environmental law
which
basically recognizes the rights of
nature in the same way as
human rights so the fact that it's
approved these oil projects
appears incompatible at least
it's extraordinary that this law came
through
around the same time that the government
was pressing ahead with this
oil project the big question is will
this new rights of late
rights of nature law stop the old
project
almost certainly not well joining me now
from kampala for more on this
is dennis tabarro executive director of
the african institute for culture and
ecology
welcome to you i understand that you've
been working with
indigenous elders in the area what role
do you think that these
communities can play in shaping
environmental protections
the indigenous communities who have been
living
in this land for so many years
and they have uh been leaving
uh and practicing their customer laws uh
which
have been uh uh used for
uh protection of their uh ancestral
lands
and and cultural heritage
and they are
attuned to the laws of nature and
they respect the laws of nature which
are embedded
in their customer roles well as you say
these people have been preserving the
land for generations haven't they
do you think they have lessons for the
rest of the world in terms of protecting
the environment
yes uh they they uh provide lessons
because
uh their customer laws are part
and parcel of uh the natural laws
are the laws of nature and they live
in that part of in those laws
they don't go to school to learn about
about environment they don't go to
school to learn about
nature they naturals are part and parcel
of
of their lives and for them
their land and their ancestral laws are
sacred
and everything that is there in nature
is sacred
and they follow the laws of nature
dennis tabara thanks very much indeed
thank you
that's everything from us for this week
but don't forget to check out our
digital
show over the weekend and in the latest
episode we go behind the scenes of adam
parsons report
into the german coal mine demolishing
entire villages
that's available on sky news social
channels our app and our website
and on climatecast this week we hear
more from bangladesh
and the challenges and highlights of
filming in a country on the front line
of the climate emergency
you can find that wherever you normally
get your podcast from thanks for
watching
see you next week
you